nintendo is officially confirmed to be
returning to e3 2021
will it be a nintendo direct and a few
days to treehouse live
considering recent years yeah probably
but that doesn't stop us from dreaming
of game reveals like we always do
nintendo tends to bring out the big guns
at e3 so here's 9 things that i evan
langer
mr nintendo for gamespot video want from
nintendo at e3 2021
at the february nintendo direct aj onuma
confirmed that more breath of the wild 2
news would be coming later this year
well i can't think of a better time than
e3 no rest to the developer since
pretty much everything has been delayed
due to all the happenings in the world
but getting breath of the wild to this
year for the 35th anniversary of zelda
would be
number one epic victory royale how do
you do fellow kids
what if you want to know what we'd like
to see in the breath of the wild sequel
then i recommend you check out the video
i did with max blumenthal which i'll
link in the description below
although admittedly breath of the wild
was supposed to come out in 2016 for the
30th anniversary but got pushed to 2017
and that game was still great so who
cares about anniversaries
speaking of anniversaries if by this
point we haven't heard anything about
zelda's 35th anniversary i think this
would be the perfect place for nintendo
to talk about it
think about it when we're ghd plus
twilight princess hd on twitch and 64
online with the first titles being
ocarina of time majora's mask
oracle seeds and ages remake being
teased for 2021 or later four swords and
four swords adventures coming to the
eshop
okay not all those things will happen
but i'd like wind waker hd and twilight
princess hd at least
before you say anything i'm not a port
beggar i promise but hear me out
if persona 5 royal came to switch to
complement persona 5 strikers
i would like that a lot persona 5 royal
is one of my favorite games of all time
and i love playing through it on
playstation
but i see the switch more and more as a
great place to house some of the older
persona titles like persona 3 fps and
persona 4 golden
but you didn't see that one coming
given the classic psn stores closing the
list of modern platforms to play persona
3 and 4 on is shrinking
if nintendo were to announce both these
titles on switch i'm sure it'd be huge
persona 4 on pc lit up the steam charts
when it was announced
i would also like the persona q games to
come to switch so they aren't locked to
3ds but i imagine 3 and 4 is a safer
wish
think about this metroid prime 4 gets a
new teaser trailer with the release date
of 2022
and nintendo announces that yes metroid
prime trilogy is coming to switch in
early 2022
and metroid samus returns is being
ported to switch
happy 35th birthday samus least i
remembered will nintendo do anything for
metroid's 35th birthday
probably not anyways
completely biased here but i love pikmin
if you haven't played pikmin 3 deluxe
you
absolutely should the franchise never
took off in any meaningful ways but with
nintendo using pikmin as their next
mobile game
i think now is the best time to release
an official fourth entry you know how it
goes
people download the mobile game and they
like it so they look for more pikmin
which they find on switch
it's one big marketing circle and i'm
here for it
say what you will about nintendo's
legacy offerings through its online
service
but at this point it really should
expand beyond nes and snes
i know there's likely some tricky
emulation stuff to do under the hood and
it's probably not as easy as just
quickly pouring the games over
but with xbox really committing to not
only preserving old games but improving
them
i'd love to see nintendo follow suit n64
seems like the next step and i'm fully
in support of it but it's time for
gamecube to get the legacy treatment
both the wii and wii u virtual consoles
skipped over the gamecube and the price
of almost every gamecube game has
skyrocketed on the secondhand market
super smash bros melee pikmin 1 and 2
luigi's mansion
monkey ball 1 and 2 shark tail mario
kart double dash and the list goes on
nintendo please
good all right can't touch this
can't touch this arms 2 yeah you heard
me
arms is sweet and it's one of my
favorite fighting games the biggest
thing i'd want from a sequel is a proper
story mode
really dig deep into the lore of this
world where people get extendable arms
by putting on a mask and how some people
are born with it while others aren't
add some new characters to complement
the remainder of the cast too
arm sold well and i think it
simultaneously came out at a good and
bad time
good in that it was the first year of
the switch so it was a hot new item
bad in that it was sandwiched between
breath of the wild and splatoon 2.
arms 2 will get its time to shine i know
it spurring to the top
a lot of people don't like the wii u
games on switch thing and i do get it
but i personally like it
there are a lot of games i missed on wii
u for one reason or another and having
these titles accessible to more people
is always a good thing with miitopia
being announced for switch in the
february nintendo direct i hope this is
the start of more 3ds games coming to
switch
if they announced a link between world
hd i would buy it in a heartbeat and
triforce heroes with proper online play
and chat would make a mediocre game
slightly better
by this point you could probably tell i
like zelda a lot but there are dozens of
other amazing 3ds games that deserve a
second life on switch
and whatever nintendo chooses i'm
excited it's witch time
[Music]
and that's it enough said on that now of
course i don't expect all these things
to happen and i'm fully in support of
developers taking the time they need to
make the games the best they can be
but i wanted to throw all this into the
wild to see if anything will stick
anything you want to see from nintendo
at e3 2021 let us know in the comments
below and for all the latest on nintendo
stay tuned to gamespot
[Music]
foreign